how are you doing today sir uh very very
well and all the better for seeing you
how you doing
um listen i'm doing great i um if i look
down it's because you know i'm looking
at some stuff that i may have prepared
you know questions
um
uh yes so first let me start by saying
congrats on the movie so i like throwing
some curve balls right at the beginning
to ask about some you know what i mean i
just don't want to spend you know so i
read that you are the executive producer
on next goal wins how did that come
about
um well uh well that that was a script
that we developed and um and then we
reached out to oh that's at the
imaginarium our production company
so yeah so we we reached out to taika
and uh we're very very excited that he
wanted to
to direct it
and uh and lo and behold
you know he came and we shot the movie
and it's turning out great it's
fantastic do you think it's so different
than what tyka has done before
um are you uh what can you tease people
about it
um i i just think it's one of the most
it's one of the most incredible football
stories of all time it really is it's
such a beautiful tale and a very it's
it's
you know
anybody who likes football will love
this movie soccer particularly not
american football but uh you know and
but it's just such a it's a really
heartfelt story about community that
that comes together because they love
doing what they do they do and and and
and the kind of
the
it's about about being forced in a
direction to achieve that doesn't suit
or kind of mean
anything to them other than the
enjoyment of the game that they love
playing being pushed into a thing
however you know they go through trials
and tribulations and and and they come
out on top
and and in a nutshell really i suppose
you've worked with such talented
directors and i'm curious what have you
cribbed from them while on set that you
wanted to take with you when you get
behind the camera
well obviously the you know the person
i've worked mostly with is is peter
jackson goes without saying i've learned
an enormous amount from him because he's
given me great opportunities to learn
from him um you know offering me such
things as the second unit directorship
of
during the hobbit and
but but what what
really
sticks out to me about peter as a
director is this incredible ability to
trust his
his team and to and to lead in in such a
way that that that enables everyone to
give 150 and and kind of and
make that he makes everybody feel
incredibly valued for for what they do
and and and yeah creates an atmosphere
of of um of constantly challenging um
kind of like a cauldron of creativity
that keeps swirling around and
but all the time sort of being forensic
and detailed about the outcome and
exactly what he wants but just allowing
the best idea in the room to to rise to
the surface i think
yeah i've heard that about spielberg
that one of the reasons he's so good is
he listens to everybody on set for ideas
i think that's i think that's true i
think it's
the mark of a great direction you know
when you're aspiring or kind of
a young director i think you somehow
feel you've got to control everything
and and and you yes you know it's a
certain extent when you're honing your
the idea of what your vision might be
that's important you still have to you
still have to trust and and and not fear
um other great ideas that are coming
your way and shut them down so that's
that's that's true
i'm curious i want to go backwards in
time before you got the gig and when you
met with sony about the project how what
was that like when you walk in what is
it like for you like to walk in and sort
of pitch the studio on your idea for the
movie and do you get nervous when you're
doing something like that
well in a way i didn't actually have to
do that on this because they reached out
to me and it was through tom you know
tom hardy reached out to me because tom
and i have known each other for a long
long time and
have wanted to work with each other and
literally both as actors with each other
and
and also as you know with me directing
they've been other opportunities in the
past that have almost happened and
haven't quite but but it was tom who
reached out to me um before before
you know and just said look andy we
we've been talking and we're looking for
someone to to take on this this second
part of the journey of venom and
we love the idea of doing it you you
know can i throw your hat in the ring
for the direct ship and i so i so so i i
was
yeah i was extremely flattered and then
when i we talked and i talked to kelly
marcel and obviously tom and kelly had
been right sort of
you know creating the story together and
then kelly had written the script and i
read that i read the script and it i was
just
so super excited about about what was in
there which was this amazing um
departure from the first movie whereby
now you have a mature relationship of
these of these two central characters uh
that are that are so dysfunctional and
hilarious and touching and moving and
you know um and they they they can't
live with and can't live without each
other it was so rich and fertile plus
you get the introduction of you know one
of the great super villains of
of the of the universe you know so
so
it's um it was it wasn't it was just a
no-brainer and i and i i i just yeah so
i so i
didn't have to do what you said you know
which is to go in a pitch i was i was
very lucky in in the sense that i was
reached out too
and
i'm so thankful for that because i had a
ball making it
did you tell tom that the only reason
the only way i will make this sequel is
if i get to get rid of woody's wig from
the first film
i think i think that was a group
decision because there had been such you
know and tom tom hardy's talked about
this you know that after the first film
came out and you know there were
the critics were quite tough on it
although the fans absolutely adored him
everybody went to see it
um you know
listening to the fans was really
important and you know what was like
what wasn't liked and one of the things
that came up which we thought was going
to be a distraction was was was the the
way that cletus's hair you know looked
in that first movie and that it would
just it wouldn't allow we
that in a way you wouldn't be able to
get past it and with what he had to do
in this story in terms of the
seriousness the darkness the kind of the
emotional truth of the character there's
something inherently kind of comic about
that which in the wrong way so so so we
all agreed you know that that it was it
was time to uh for him to have a haircut
before this
this this movie started and that it
would logically imprison
you know you'd get a trim
right i i was very happy the hair got
changed i i'm also i think i think
woody's great but that hair needed to go
you know um so uh i always love learning
about how things change during the
developing of any project from when you
guys started working on it to what
people ended up seeing on screen or
we'll see on the screen were there any
really big changes along the way or was
it pretty much
what you what tom pitched you and kelly
mentioned to you back when you first got
involved
i think the essence of it was was
absolutely there and it was a very it
was always a very lean muscular roller
coaster ride that was only gonna you
know
the the timer which was going to be an
allotted 90 minutes you know we wanted
it to move fast to have pace to have
carnage kind of tear the thing up when
he arrived on screen as early as we
could make it happen without rushing all
the character uh you know the openings
for the characters that we needed to
establish and and necessarily spend time
with uncovering and cr you know creating
the relationship of eddie and venom for
instance but but it was always that lean
for sure um
but in terms of things that grew i mean
there were lots of things that grew
organically the the relationship with
the the you know the fight scene in the
apartment you know there was it was it
was meant one line in the script you
know it grew into this whole thing you
know moments that that we felt oh look
we can really mine this and have fun you
know really exemplify what it is exactly
specifically is going on between them at
this moment in time um you know the the
escape from san quentin grew and as we
previously changed and you know made it
into a sort of made made carnage into it
this you know the moments where it's
almost like an aerial ballet as his ten
rules of whipping him from scientists
all of those sorts of you know um
creative choices
you know took us in a particular
direction and then you know in the in
the in the
battle royale you know the the noom on
the be kind of toe to toe which there is
only you know we we we only have one big
toe to toe head to head with uh venom
and carnage and purposefully we wanted
that but how we supported just you know
that yes having two symbiotes fight is
interesting but how we underpinned that
fight with that with the reality of of
the relationship between eddie and
cletus and how that would play out
you know simultaneously that that again
was something that really grew and
changed and morphed during the
production
uh the title is obviously venom let
there be carnage at any point did you
guys discuss having it being venom
lethal protector or some other version
of the title
um we
it's
not really nothing to do with lethal
protector at this point um we did think
for a moment it might be called
um
love will tear us apart that was quite
that was that was that was a kind of a
going concern for a little while but but
but let there be kindness just seemed to
you know just seem to do it it just
there wasn't a lot of um
fighting in the fighting over the other
titles that we were thinking of because
this was such a strong contender
also you want to save lethal protector
for maybe the next one it's just a
possibility but yeah yeah yeah yeah um
so one of the things about venom and
carnage both of them require a lot of vf
obviously it's vfx so i'm curious going
in is there any sort of like note from
the studios saying hey you know we can
afford 25 minutes of vfx so figure out
how you want to use it does that come
into play at all during the because
obviously it has to be budgeted i'm just
curious how that gets worked out
yeah no i mean
when you go into production
everything everything is kind of like
how can we make this without spending so
much money you know
in a lean way and part of the discipline
when you're pre-visiting part of the
discipline when you're you know when
you're creating an idea or having ideas
um you know you can try every you can
let your mind go wild and try out
everything in the early stage of
previous because it's it's not rendered
nothing is rendered you only start
really spending money of course when
you're rendering shots
so you can let the imagination run wild
in in pre pre-production then of course
when you then you when you get to
production you have to start nailing
down exactly what you're going to shoot
for real what elements are going to be
physical elements what
you know
you know that's gonna that probably is
gonna cost too much if you do that
that's gonna get very expensive so so
yeah but of course it's a sort of horse
train it gets to a horse training kind
of moment where you um
where you have to cut your cloth to a
certain extent then
when you when it starts to go into to to
the the kind of the rendering phase and
then then
you know then you're
you're really having to
spend the money making the shots look as
best as possible and photo real and you
know integrated and integrate the cg
into into the cinematography and and
that's something for instance on this
movie in particular that was a big
challenge because those designs the
designs in the comics and of the
characters of carnage and venom they're
not forgiving you know they're they're
very bold kind of cartoon-like almost
and it's hard to bring them into the
real
real world so you need an expert
cinematographer ah bob richardson uh you
know you came in and worked with the
brilliant visual effects uh supervisor
sheena dougal who worked on the first
movie and that was one of the first
things i was really mostly um concerned
about
not concerned about but wanted to get
right was that i wanted to make it
shoot it in such a way that these things
felt real physical you felt their mass
you felt their interaction with the
environment felt the interaction with
light you know and that that is that
that was what we really really worked
hard on in this movie
um without getting into spoilers uh or
discussing it specifically but i am
curious with the after the credit scene
was that always planned for
from the beginning like and did you you
know could you sort of talk about
because it's a pretty significant scene
hypothetically it was it was
not thought about from from at the
beginning it was it was i mean there was
obviously you know um
you know uh
there were talks about what it was that
we were we wanted to leave the movie but
but that certainly was was not um
a foregone conclusion at the beginning
for sure
well with something like that is that
something obviously that's very
significant to the big marvel sony
everything i would imagine so when did
you actually did you film that during
the production or was that like an
add-on that was that was all shot after
the fact
exactly i want to ask so many more
questions but i'll leave it there and
just you know um uh so um i really
enjoyed one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is the club scene um i love it
it's just it's just such a fun scene can
you sort of talk about who came up with
that idea and actually pulling it off on
screen
sure so it was always going to be a kind
of
because this was always going to be a
kind of halloween time movie we wanted
to create a day of the dead or carnival
of the damned sort of
festival
kind of almost like a big uh lgbtqia
kind of feel festival
um that venom suddenly finds himself in
as an outsider and then realizes that
these you know now he as he says in the
movie you know i'm out of the eddie
closet he's he's here he's arrived and
he actually feels
not judged or looked at or you know so
so that was that was always that was
always a plan um
however
we had the great good fortune of tom
hardy knowing little sims and she kind
of just after the film around the time
of after the first movie um she wrote a
song called venom which was completely
unrelated to the movie or the character
it was just something that she'd written
about and
um
and and so tom thought wow god it'd be
incredible if we could get her to
sing it for this you know for this for
for for us in the movie which she she
did and came on board and so that that
was a that was a kind of an addition
later on but yeah so so and then when we
got there it was like wow this is going
to be we wanted it to be big and you
know we had
and and thank goodness it was before
coving hit um we were able to shoot with
650 supporting artists um over about
three days i believe it was three days
or three night shoots um and it was
amazing it was amazing and quite i mean
although we storyboarded it and you know
certain parts of it storyboarded it it
still hadn't we wanted it to have an
organic feel and so so really it was
just sort of picking little vignette
moments um which we wanted to bring to
life and
in the in the location that we were
shooting and then we had all these
incredible puppets as well and people on
stilts all of that um so we sort of
thread a story around a journey towards
discovering little sims singing that
song and then and then his and then
venom you know um taking the stage
so so it was so it was a it was a it was
a very complicated but but quite organic
uh process yeah i love that scene i know
i'm basically out of time but i have to
ask you one other thing i'm a big fan of
luther and i know you're a part i know
you're a part of luther and i really
want to know um what can you tease about
your role in the film and also when are
you making it are you filming it now
um i can tell you that i haven't started
shooting yet but uh the shooting will
start
relatively soon um but of course i can't
really tell you too much about the
character that i'm playing at this point
it would be a bit unfair and
um so so yeah but it's i'm super excited
about about joining the franchise
because i i i really genuinely love
luther i think it's you know i think
idris elba's character is just stunning
and and uh you know
it's a it's it's just a very very
interesting world and i'm i'm
really excited to work with jamie payne
the director who directs the last series
series five so so yeah i know i'm
looking forward to that
yeah i'm just so excited that uh they're
finally making the movie you know
they've talked about yeah he's talked
about it forever and i just never
thought it was going to happen and now
it is you know hey listen congrats on
everything um i wish i hope this is a
huge hit for you and uh thank you for
giving me your time oh thanks it's
always great to see them cool thanks
have a great day man
cheers
you